- [Narrator] Welcome back.
So we've learned that it's important
to keep working through your frustrations
by using the right learning strategies.
The more you work
through your frustration,
the more your brain grows, right.
But it can be difficult to
work through that frustration
without a clear direction.
That's why it's important to make
smart goals.
It's an acronym.
It goes like this.
Specific,
measurable,
actionable,
realistic,
timely.
Because look,
you can wish all you want
and say one day I'm gonna go to the moon.
And you can want that like
your life depended on it.
But a wish
is not a goal.
An example of a moon plan
that consists of smart goals
would go something like this.
In 20 years,
I will have studied enough
physics and chemistry,
flown jet planes in the Air Force,
worked out four times a week,
and gotten a job as a astronaut for NASA.
And this will enable
me to fly a spacecraft
to the moon
and put my feet on it for science reasons.
Specific.
Put your feet on the moon.
Measurable.
Are your feet touching
the surface of the moon?
Actionable.
It is actionable,
that is to say doable,
to study physics and chemistry,
enlist in the Air Force,
and go to the gym.
Realistic.
It's hard, but it's not impossible
to become an astronaut.
Timely, here's where
more realism kicks in.
You won't be able to go to the moon
as an astronaut overnight.
20 years seems a little more reasonable.
But let's take this back to a more
sensible time scale
and look at our friend, Thinky Pinky.
Hey buddy.
TP here is interested in pull ups,
wants to be able to lift their entire mass
with just the arms, this one.
But pull ups are hard.
So let's take a look at Thinky
Pinky's reflection journal.
Quote, I want to be able to do
two consecutive pull ups
by the end of the year
by practicing pull ups at the gym
three times per week.
Why is this a smart goal?
S is for specific.
TP wants to work on pull ups.
And they're not interested
in biking or weight training.
There's one skill that Thinky Pinky
wants to work on
and that's pull ups.
M is for measurable.
What's the metric for TP's success?
Two in a row.
Two pull ups,
one right after the other.
You've either done it or you haven't.
Measurable.
A is for actionable.
Can it be broken down
into individual tasks.
Yeah.
Go into the gym three
times a week to practice
feels very actionable indeed.
R is for realistic.
TP's not training to lift a car.
Just some pull ups.
T is for timely.
There's a time limit on this.
Thinky Pinky wants to do
this in a year's time.
All together, that's smart
goal you got there, TP.
With the power of persistence,
smart goals, and the right kind of help,
you can do anything you set your mind to.
You can learn anything.
Happy goal setting.